good afternoon
it's gonna announce the results of the
second ballot in the leadership election
as yesterday I'll read the name of the
candidate and the number of folks cast
in each case uh first of all 356 votes
were cast out of a possible 358.
the numbers are as follows badanok 49
Braverman 27
mordant 83
sunac 101
Truss 64.
2 condat 32 therefore under the rules
Sue Ella bravaman
is eliminated from the contest and the
others are able to go forward to a
further ballot on Monday
thank you there you go the results are
in the person who has been eliminated is
Sue Ella Brotherman Herbert actually
going down from 32 in the first ballot
to 27 today you can see there Richie
sunac clearing the 100 mark on 101 penny
mordant in second place again on 83 Liz
truss on 64. can we Batten up on 49
increasing her boat share there and you
can see there at Tom Tigger hat just
tweaking through or 32 his boat number
going down to let's go to our political
editor Beth Rigby what do you make of
the results then well um that that's
that's an interesting set of results
look what rather man is out so that is
one candidate out and she dropped votes
she went back five and Tom tugenhatt he
is still in there but he's also lost
votes and you have to ask yourself at
this point does Tom tugan hat decide to
fold Now sources around him insisted to
me that that had not been a conversation
nation that had had that he was very
keen to go into any live TV debates if
he could but let's see what Tom tugan
now does he's losing support that is not
where you want to be but look at the
main Runners Rishi sunak has got over a
hundred he now is only 19 votes away
from uh getting to that magic 120 figure
and he's put on what let me 13 votes so
he's taken a chunk of that 43 that split
maybe maybe not as much as he might have
wanted but anyway look he's over the
hundred mark what's interesting with
Morgan is she's put on another let me
try and do them as 16 votes so she'll be
happy with that I think she's still in
second place she's gone up to the mid
80s or the low 80s and Trust I think
what you can see there she's put on 14
votes she's still quite clearly trailing
more than not managing to close the gap
but isn't it interesting Sophie that
Braverman lost five votes and it seems
to me that as Sam was talking about
earlier that sowella Bradman some of
those candidates may be moving to try
and bolster Liz trust but she's still
clearly in third place I mean I think
from those results we have to see where
brother man where the rest of those
votes go you would think that they would
perhaps lean towards a trust candidate
rather than a mordant candidate given
that penny more than whilst a conviction
brexiteer is more progressively liberal
on the sort of liberal conservative wing
on the party when it comes to social
policy so I'm not sure bravaman
supporters would think that penny
mordant is their woman but Morden will
be pleased with that Sonic will be
relieved to get over a hundred and Trust
there she really does have to make up
some ground because looking at those
numbers when we talk about whether Rishi
sunak can lend votes in order to block
other people you've got to be really
comfortably over the 120 mark to risk in
the later rounds lending votes out I
would say from that Liz truss looking in
a bit of trouble as Penny Morden becomes
after two rounds the clear second
favorite to sanak
really interesting to see as you say
Beth there the change in numbers
compared to yesterday really I think
showing at how the momentum is changing
Penny Morden actually the candidate
putting on the most votes against 16 Liz
trust up 14 Rishi sunak up 13. and so
you can see where the votes are going
and as you were saying there Beth it
feels like momentum is everything with
both Zoella Brotherman and Tom Tegan had
actually losing votes I wonder you know
our surrounds progress can you see Liz
trust potentially at picking up more
votes if you think that perhaps Zoella
Brotherman and Kevin could be the next
two candidates to be eliminated both
people from the or the right of the
party yeah so if you're doing actually
if you let's talk a bit about Kami
badenot because she is a former Minister
but look at that she's come in with 49
votes she's going to be extremely
pleased with that performance she in a
way has become another Dark Horse in in
the race on the right of the party
winning the patronage the support of
Michael Gove a key backup for her and
she's come in at 49 in in fourth place
but I guess the question is as this goes
along to badanoc backers and do um
bravaman backers uh go to trust and can
she lift her numbers up but they might
also break uh farishi sunap because many
people will think MPS will now think my
first choice is out I'm gonna go for my
second preference who is the one that's
most likely to win who is the one that
might put me back in their cabinet or
might give me a job in government and
they could also break uh for sunak he of
that 43 votes that were going spare
after zahawi and Hunt were knocked out
sunax picked up 14 votes he's got over a
hundred uh has picked up 14 votes from
the last round but I imagine that she
might have picked up some of those
Braverman votes and as for Tom tugenhart
could it be as well that some of those
back in Tom tugenhart are now pushing
into the mordant column she as well
describes herself as a one-nation
conservative whilst also being a
conviction uh brexiteer are they trying
to uh move his column uh to Modern so
she could pick up those votes I mean I
think the main takeaway in terms of how
it's breaking down is it's going to be
very tight potentially between mordant
and Trust providing that trust can pick
up the Lion's Share of those badanoc
votes but it could be that um they go
they split to Rishi sunak as well it's
really unpredictable
yeah as you're saying Beth that unlike
the election with Boris Johnson unlike
the election with Theresa May it really
feels that like this race is very
difficult to call and we were discussing
before we got the result that it does
look at like Rishi sinaka is the most
likely candidate to be on the final two
which will then of course be put to
party members do you think the result
today is another indication that he does
look like he's on track to reach that
final too
it's team now you've got a over a
hundred he's now in Striking Distance of
the magic 120. he's consistently been in
the lead but it's not a load of clear
blue water between him and other
candidates in the way that with Boris I
mean Boris Johnson was just streaks
ahead of the others back in 2019 that is
not the case uh for sanak uh but you
know he is on 101 he's the only one to
break the three-digit Mark he is tapping
on potentially that 120 he will surely
be confident within his team that
between uh badanok Braverman and
tugenhart he can pick up enough uh other
supporters there's lots of questions as
well whether Michael Gove uh wants kemi
badenock does fall out of the race which
unless there is a a massive shock she
surely will at the final rounds whether
Michael Gove moves his support to Rishi
sunak as well with with other senior
cabinet ministers falling in in behind
Rishi sunak so as far as Rishi sunax
concerned there was an expectation or
quiet confidence in his team yesterday
after the first round that he would make
it to the final two there's nothing in
those numbers that would make them panic
yet but if you were Liz truss you might
be getting quite worried that you could
be knocked out of this race you've got
to see what happens with those bad
enough numbers and as I said one reason
she could be carried through is not on
the back of just her vote but on the
back of Rishi sunak who would probably
rather meet her in the final uh hustins
the final two the mordant whether he
might lend votes to try and block trust
but on those figures at the moment
unless something radically changes and
he suddenly puts on 60 70 parliamentary
votes he's not going to be in a position
to lend many votes so it's going to be a
straight fight at the moment for the
final two but it can all change I think
we don't have any votes now until next
week so there's going to be a lot of
action over this weekend as those still
in the running try and win over other
supporters let's see what Tom tugenhart
does as well because as I said he is
losing momentum he has dropped five
votes will he fold the cards now or will
he decide that actually I quite fancy
the platform of having some leaders
debates where I can go Toe to Toe with
some of my colleagues I mean the problem
Tom tugen has in all of this race as you
know Sophie is that he was not put into
Boris Johnson's cabinet he has always
been an opponent opponent of Boris
Johnson and it means that he just does
not have the cabinet experience that you
would perhaps want to see if you're an
MP from a candidate that doesn't want to
just run the conservative party but
needs to run at the country ahead of
another general election so what will
Tom tugenhart do I I'm looking I'm
looking to see what he does now I'm sure
he's gonna have to put a statement out
one way or the other quite soon given
that he's dropped five votes Braverman
is out having dropped five votes also
very much for your
an event is going to be a really a
fierce weekend of campaigning ahead of
the next ballot which is due on Monday
including of course and those TV debates
well joining us now to get a bit more
reaction to the second ballot results is
the former house secretary Matt Hancock
which is feedback as a supporter and
what do you make of today's results well
clearly this is a big vote of confidence
in Rishi sunak a clear winner and with
over a hundred colleagues backing him
it's a good reason for that because he's
proved to be the candidate with the
strong clear economic plan to get us
through difficult times and he's also
the candidate who can most clearly beat
kirst armor and protect this country
from starmer and Nicholas sturgeon
ripping it up in the future so you know
on on the big things that really matter
Rishi is ahead and that's reflected in
the in the results of the poll today you
say he's ahead he clearly is ahead
clearing the hundreds yeah but is he the
candidate with momentum it was Morgan
who picked up most of those today she
perhaps surprised people with her
showing at the first ballot has been
polling suggesting that she is Marve
ahead in terms of popularity with
conservative party members is she
perhaps the one who's coming up on the
inside track well there have been polls
of party members saying rishi's ahead
have been polls saying that pennies
ahead and we've got those recent polling
shows ahead well these polls are
notoriously difficult with
targeting the Tory members in terms of
the polling what matters is the debate
that we'll no doubt have over the next
six weeks
with highly likely the which he will get
through now and I and whether it's um
Penny or Liz or kemi or Tom who are left
in the race and we'll go out and have
that big debate out in the country
and the candidates will be tested and
challenged and one of the things about
Rishi is that he has been tested and
challenged in possibly the most
difficult circumstances that the country
has faced in peacetime history I work
with him on that sat next term through
it and he's got the experience so you
know I know that he's got that uh he's
got that
that time that he's spent at the
Forefront right in the heart of In the
Heat of this these huge debates so you
know whether it's having the plan or
being able to beat kirst armor because
she's the lead I mean you obviously work
closely with Russia students but other
cabinet colleagues have got a bit of a
different view of it I think Jacob B
small describes him as a socialist
Chancellor well of course Richie brought
in furlough and saved literally millions
of jobs and I think that's one of the
reasons that he is ahead when it comes
to the public and one of the reasons
that he's more popular than kirstana
unlike all the other candidates is
because the public do recognize the
extraordinary lengths he went to to
protect people's lives and livelihoods
during the pandemic but of course it's
about plans for the future but she's set
out credible economic plan firstly
dealing with inflation getting growth
going which is critical and then cutting
taxes is a responsible
credible plan on the economy and I think
that's why the public increasingly uh
warming to British sooner in the public
but it's conservative part of members
yeah but there's a long way to go in
that debate it is a long way we're about
four days in so far you know it is a
long way to go but if you look at the
Hugo he basically loses pretty much
every final one off with his survival
Steve bacon was there saying that
whoever goes up against Russia soon
after the finals who is going to win
among conservative party members if you
don't support Russia you would say that
wouldn't you what matters is the is the
debate that we're going to have no doubt
in the country I think it's highly
likely that Hershey's name will be on
that ballot paper I certainly hope it
will and how much do you think will be
on the ballot I don't know there's four
others and you know there's the three
horse race really though right
um no there's four others it's five
horse race now it was six this morning
so you know that's the purpose of this I
don't think you should rule anybody out
um but what is clear is that there's a
very strong vote of confidence in Rishi
over a hundred of my uh my colleagues in
fact plus me 100 101 in total colleagues
backing Rishi and the reason is because
he's got the economic plan and he's the
one of polling consistently shows can be
here at starmat and winning the next
election is incredibly important for my
party you talk a lot about Rishi zunax
economic wow yeah are you concerned
about the tax promises that are being
thrown around by some of the other
candidates and how are they going to be
funded is this realistic economics well
I think it's incredibly important that
we put forward as a party a responsible
credible economic plan people look to us
yes of course to get the burden of tax
down but first and foremost to make sure
that the economy is strong and that we
have responsible policy that is the
first task of a conservative government
with inflation running at 10 that is
incredibly important even more important
and you know we haven't had inflation at
these levels for
for a generation so we've got to deal
with inflation then we can get on to
cutting tax I think that's the
responsible and the right approach and
by the way I think it's also the
approach that will appeal to
conservative party members as well as
the general public well not wrong to
find out Matt Hancock thank you very
much
today Matt Hancock there talking about
his supports for Rishi sunak who tops
the bowl poll uh today we have just got
a Twitter statement that's come through
from Tom toogen who of course did manage
to get over the line today with more
votes than Zola brother meant but his
votes went down he got 32 this time
compared to 37 last time so he actually
lost about five votes he's tweeted
though to say the campaign for a clean
start continues thank you to all my
friends and colleagues who have pledged
to their support we need trust back in
our politics I will be putting my vision
for Britain forward to the public at the
TB debates next week so interesting
there probably going to have some
speculation that he may have decided to
step aside after the disappointing
showing today but no he is decided to
remain in the contest in order to keep
on going with that fight but we're
joined Now by Simon Clark who is the
chief secretary to the treasury he is
somebody who's backing Liz truss how did
you why did you decide to back Liz trust
the president that you worked with
Brushy sooner I'm a huge amount of Liz I
backed her predominantly because of her
economic strategy which I think is
pro-growth pro-enterprise low tax what
we need to see at a time when crucially
we've got to Galvanize growth and we're
going to protect the public finances and
look after people what is a really
challenging moment in the world economy
so it's interesting that you chose the
economic plan of someone that you
haven't learned in the trash rate well
I've worked very closely with all my
colleagues across government over the
course of the last year and Liz is for
me the standout candidate to be our next
legal prime minister because of her long
record in government her ability to to
draw support across this party but
crucially as I say because I think she
has the right plan for the country
um do you think is this a judgment at
all on Russia's unexpants the economy or
the fact is she were you frustrated at
times about well I think we were all
frustrated by some of the choices uh in
terms of tax uh obviously those are you
know private discussions within
government when you're bound by
Collective responsibility but I'm clear
that I favor a low tax co-enterprise
economy and I think Liz has the right
approach on that so for me this is a
policy it's a policy decision and one
which I think uh you know many
colleagues and many conservative members
will will support but look they're a
good candidates in this race I think
it's vitally important we respect but
you can legitimately disagree you were
frustrated at times then with Russia
students policy I stand by uh the
Chancellor's view on the ability to have
tax cuts against our current spending
plans but those are no longer going to
be sacrosanct because we're gonna have a
new prime minister and a new policy and
this she will have a spending review on
day one set out different choices on the
underlying spending plans of the
government which creates obviously
different Headroom uh fraction on tax
I'm interested to know your thoughts on
another candidate as well Penny Morton
she in some ways is a candidate with
momentum she put on the most amount of
votes today at all the candidates and
Lord Frosty obviously part of the brexit
negotiations has spoken out to say that
he has concerns over her he said that he
had to ask boss Johnson to actually move
her off the brexit negotiations and she
was looking for a job you then tweeted
to say that the warning is a very
serious one a conservatives and far more
important than our country need a leader
who is tested and ready I stand by that
that's absolutely my view and David has
worked very closely with a number of the
colleagues who are standing in this race
and I think we have to listen to what
he's saying because in the end this is
about choosing not just actually to the
conservative party of Alex prime
minister and it is telling I think where
current members of the government are
placing their support and I think you
know that is reflected in Davis comments
but also reflected in a number of very
senior ministers decisions about who to
support in this race they are not
backing this morning are you worried
that she's basically not ready for the
job though well I think it is no I think
it is to to make that make their own
minds up I'm not here to lecture but
David Frost is a very senior figure in
search of politics he's worked very
closely with as I say all the major
players in this race he's made his views
known I think that is a material Factor
concerned to argue about Liz trussell's
performance so far sorry over how about
this trusted performance so far she's in
third place I I have every confidence in
Liz I think we're in a very good
position in this race relative to where
we might expect to be at this point
obviously now that Mr bravaman is going
out of the race uh there will be an
opportunity for us to speak to a number
of people who share Liz's views on uh on
the European question and so you feel
that actually in this trust those
numbers May tick up I hope so I very
much hope so we'll be having those
conversations over the days ahead so you
are going to be trying to speak to
another problem we certainly will be but
obviously we have to respect her
decision to give her the time and space
that she needs have you had any
conversations with her campaign team
obviously we continue to have
conversations with people right across
the party uh but uh I'm sure those were
intentimes the days ahead okay thank you
very much thank you very much
they're speaking to us they're
interesting his comments saying that
there were frustrations about the level
of tax that he had when he was working
in the treasury alongside Rishi sunac
and also of course we have just seen a
tweet coming through from Rishi sunak
now he received the highest number of
boats in his second leadership ballot he
said I'm incredibly grateful for the
continued support from my colleagues in
The Wider public I am prepared to give
everything I have in service to our
nation together we can restore trust
rebuild our economy and reunite the
country
what we're doing now by our Deputy
political editor Sam Kate so who's with
us now Sam I just want a few Reflections
on that interview with Simon Clark Liz
trust supporter I was quite struck I
guess by the criticism of Penny Waters
at who he said he agreed with North
Frost there were concerns about whether
she's tested but also Rishi sunak and
the frustrations that he was airing
about someone he can work closely with
with regards to tax it's one thing for
the former brexit negotiator Lord Frost
to try and as it were really take out
penny more than on the basis of them
working together in his uh views about
how she would govern the country but
it's quite something else to watch what
Simon Clark he was a member of the
cabinet just did standing by his
comments basically suggesting that she
wouldn't have the necessary experience
to run the United Kingdom that is
exactly the kind of Blue on Blue that
after this leadership contest is going
to be so difficult to put back in the
box that's the kind of fissure that does
lasting damage here now it reflects a
political reality that we're seeing this
morning and playing out in the numbers
which is concerned amongst those
supporting Liz truss that suddenly there
was a new Insurgent in the form of Penny
wardens and so that's why there's been
quite a concerted campaign against her
through the last few hours now what
we've seen in the numbers today is
you've seen again penny more than do
well and again Liz trusting a step
change up but perhaps not as big as it
would be but here's where the really
difficult task starts and I think it's
going to be very interesting because if
you talk to supporters of all the camps
behind the scenes what they're saying is
that you there is basically a a sort of
a question do the brexiteers currently
backing sowella Brethren that has just
gone out and kemi Baden who hasn't uh so
well obviously cannot win even I don't
think Kenny babe not stands it doesn't
seem to stand a very good chance at this
point do most of the supporters of both
those two leadership candidates end up
tucking behind Liz us which would take
her up to post 120 into the last two is
she suddenly going to see a surge after
this difficult round and the this is
where there's a debate supporters of Liz
trust say the answer to that is no is
yes supporters of Penny mordant say no
people like David Davis I'd like to talk
to well there you go let's talk now at
shall we at two at David Davis who is a
high profilebacker of Penny Warden I
just want to talk to you about some of
the incoming fire that we've seen at
Patty Morden at Lord Frost brexit
negotiator saying that yeah which team
is he on okay he says which team is he
on he said he had to ask
Force Johnson to move Penny Warden
because she wasn't capable of doing the
job and then we just heard just then
from Simon's park I think I know you'll
ask what teams you're on he's back in
this class he said that he's got
concerns over someone untested at being
in that job I'm testing being in the job
prime minister yes I mean and let's
trust has tested in that context well
all right let's let's leave that there's
hanging your viewers can make their own
judgments I suggest they look at each of
the launches and see which one they
think's got the character the command
the courage all right but to come back
to today and the actual news we've had
the biggest increase in the votes so far
we're further ahead of trust now we
would forward a little bit closer to uh
so it's a good day
um do you think that that's why you're
seeing some of the friendly fire shops
well yeah so cool so I wouldn't describe
it as friendly fire yeah how would you
describe that my comment my comment when
I saw it saw it earlier was right it's
absolutely Clockwork you get to the
point that somebody gets ahead and looks
like be the real Challenge and then the
Black Ops star the the incoming fast out
so what I know Penny I know better than
uh some of the people have been talking
I've worked with her for longer she's
Brave she's clear in her thinking she's
competent she covers it covers the
territory well she knows the subject
that's the penny on it that's why she's
good that's why she's ready for this job
and anybody who watched for yesterday
didn't see a fancy PR uh operation they
saw the character of the candidate come
through I suggest you your viewers watch
that who do you think is going to be the
final two then two rounds as I said to
you I think yesterday it's always
impossible to forecast these but
gradually both Mr sunak and Penny are
fully ahead
it's a slow movement apart now the next
couple of moves a more difficult
forecast because you've got brown and
you've got uh probably uh Tom tubernet
at some point uh we'll go out now how
they'll go it's very easy to think in
blocks you know but they're about as
right
forecasting in blocks is about as
reliable as forecasting and treasury
forecasts they never ever right and the
simple truth is that we don't really
know that we are battle over over their
votes and what I think's likely to
happen now is the argument's going to
turn to who a who can run the country
which is what Simon yeah and I'm clear
on that but also who can win an election
for the conservatives particularly in
the red War seats and only an hour or so
ago there's a big focus group exercise
come out it showed the only one of the
candidates that beat Starman the rebel
receipts is Penny Morton the others have
easily beaten Penny Morton easily wins
okay I haven't seen that so I can't
comment on it but um we'll take your
word for it I'm interested to get a bit
of your sense because if you have done
this before right you've run a
leadership contest before you were
beaten by the uh Insurgent if you like
uh David Cameron I wasn't really an
Insurgent it was the establishment but
never mind
but actually it ended up you know in
some ways you know you were the kind of
established candidate in that race do
you feel well I was the winning one in
the beginning exactly and then the votes
uh fell in a different ways I think that
shows perhaps what could happen with
Russia senior companion well
what you what you saw there I mean
actually it's it's a sort of reversal
Where We Are I had 60 all thereabouts of
the of the uh parliamentary votes but he
won easily in the countryside I think
when we get to the end of this it's
likely to be both of them but both uh
Rishi and Penny quite close to each
other in parliamentary votes but I think
she'll win easily in the
party in the country at least that's
what the polling yesterday and the day
before two sets of polls showed but you
know this is a this is a debate this is
a discussion about policy it's about the
future of the country it's about the
future of the Court Tory party and these
things can swing around but issues like
polls that we saw yesterday the focus
group today will all have an impact on
the thinking of MPS MPS want to do well
for their country but they also want to
win their seats yeah that's a
a true nothing like the MP's desire to
hang on to their own seat so David Davis
thank you very much I'm here dressed as
well yeah
yeah a bit more casual
yeah
well you signed up with a tie for us in
the afternoon
thank you very much
some of the the he said you wouldn't
describe its friendly Farm coming from
some of the other camps that's right but
it does Sting and I think that Penny
Warden has to prove one thing to her
colleagues which is that she does have
both the experience and the depth to be
promised and that she was actually a
Secretary of State for quite a long time
both at International Development and uh
for a slightly shorter time uh at
defense so it's not that she's got no
record here at all Ricky soon that
doesn't actually have a huge amount of
time although he was Chancellor at an
absolutely critical moment but I think
the real question uh for Penny Morton is
just what happens to all those different
groups of votes David Davis just told
you that Tory MPS don't operate in a
block no that's true but the supporters
of suelo Braverman have by and large
been members of the same ERG European
research group heartbreak to tears group
and they are not massive fans of penny
boarding so you can see that group
actually mostly moving across to Liz
truss we're still unsure is going to be
in the last two might be Richie sunac
and Liz Trust might be ready to see that
penny more than that might be Penny
Morton and Liz truss it really is a very
very difficult to call Sam Coates very
much thank you very much for your
analysis Sam there just talking about
how he expects the supporters of suela
bravaman to break she of course was
eliminated from the contest today so
it'd be interesting to see where hair
support goes in the next round and we
can speak now to somebody who's always
got his thing with the Positive where
the butt Pinchers are thinking uh Mark
Harper supporter of Richard Scenic what
do you think so other problem and
supporters are going to go well we'll
obviously be making the case to her
supporters about why they should back
wishing I think I was picking up from
the discussion what David said was right
colleagues don't move as a block you
can't assume that everybody's going to
move uh in one go I was pleased with
that result for Rishi there were 43
votes on the table from the candidates
who got knocked out and he picked up a
bigger share of them than he picked up
from the Parliamentary party in the
previous ballot so I'm very pleased with
that so I think we'll continue making
the argument about the fact that he's
the right person to set out our economic
solutions that we need the right person
to restore trust and the right person to
bring the country together and most
importantly so then please the right
person to win the next general election
and beat the labor party you say that he
picked up a better bigger share the last
time and that's what
that's what he's also the front runner
so you know we've already he picked up
the biggest share last time he picked up
a bigger share of the votes that were
available and he's gone over a hundred
so I'm very pleased with that there's
still five candidates in the race so
when you've got a lot of candidates in
the race you know it's going to take a
little while for it to shake up but he's
still in first place by some margin and
I'm very pleased with that we'll
continue making our arguments
um as we head to the the next ballot on
Monday he's the front brother who do you
think is his biggest rival looking at
the results so far well I don't know
it'll be up to conservative MPS whoever
is if he's successfully in the final
which I obviously very much hope
um he will he will debate with the
issues with whoever the other person is
take his case to members in the country
and I very much hope he'll persuade them
confidently persuade them
um but we're not we're not complacent
optimistic but not complacent and we
look forward to taking those arguments
to conservative MPS next week and what a
little bit about the tone of the debate
we spoke to Simon Clark earlier who said
that he was frustrated with Rishi sunak
in the treasury when he worked with him
quite closely because of the tax burden
do you share some of those frustrations
well look first of all I think it's
helpful if we don't personalize things
so rich has been very clear once we're
on a respectful campaign uh debate the
issues with colleagues but we won't be
getting involved in personal stuff his
record in terms of the issues right yes
and I think you've got to remember we
had a once in a 300 Richard and clear
who's going to cut taxes to when not an
if but we just had a one in a 300 year
pandemic we spent 400 billion pounds of
taxpayers money to protect millions of
jobs thousands of businesses that's why
we came out of the pandemic with the
lowest rate of unemployment for years
not with the scarring to people's lives
and opportunities that that people had
thought would happen he hasn't committed
to the same tax cuts as other countries
and I'm very pleased he hasn't because
frankly if you do unfunded tax cuts now
the danger is that you fuel inflation
and that's a massive a particularly a
big impact on poorer people and if you
have unfunded tax cuts you have no way
of paying for them how are you going to
pay for your public services so he's
been clear you you want to cut taxes but
you've got cup taxes when you can afford
it and I don't think unfunded tax cuts
are realistic particularly some people
are promising at the same time to have
massive increases in public expenditure
and it is incredible and as he said in
his video and as his launch he's not
going to be telling people fairy tales
he's going to be straight with people
tell them what they need to know not
what they want to hear so do you think
other candidates are telling fairy tales
well I think people have got to be
straightforward about how they're going
to pay for things if you if you say
you're going to cut taxes and you're
going to increase spending you've got to
be honest with me are you just going to
borrow loads of money and risk putting
up interest rates fueling inflation
which will put up people's mortgages and
damage the cost of living or do you have
a plan to pay for it so if someone says
they're going to cut taxes ask them how
are they going to pay for it if they've
got a great plan fine but I haven't
heard great plans being set out by
people that say they're going to cut
taxes
including on Sky News housed by K Burley
would you like to see Rishi seen that
take part well my understanding is and
forgive me if I've got this wrong but
the broadcast has set up the debates
without any discussion with the
candidates Rishi will have a team of
people who will be negotiating with the
broadcasters about all of the rules and
all of those guys
well I'm not going to negotiate live on
on sky with you now his team will be
doing that with with your team uh and
I'm sure they'll reach a sensible
Arrangement that everybody's happy okay
and then just finally we have seen the
Front Runners under some friendly or
unfriendly fire at Rishi
Penny Walden as well with more Foster
coming out with the extraordinary
comments effectively saying she had to
be moved
are you worried about the time of the
debate but I am a bit um Ricky was clear
respectful campaign focus on the issues
colleagues you've got to remember 5th of
September we have a new leader 6th of
September we have a new prime minister
every conservative needs to Rally behind
them so we've got to be careful that we
don't say things now that you can't
unsay so we're all colleagues and this
could be such an opportunity for the
conservative party to have an entire
summer but your profession is completely
focused on the conservative party and
the debates we're having and I want the
public to look at us and think there's
smart talented people there all of them
talented with loads of ideas about how
to take our country forward but done in
a positive respectful way and we're
being very clear with conservative MPS
we're not playing silly games
because other MPS that are supporting
Rishi we want them to vote for Rishi
we're not doing any games our whipping
operations run by my uh former whitmel
stride very respected colleague
Nel stride is running the whipping
operation very straightforward and we're
asking people a support Rishi to vote
for him and I think that's the tone that
we want to strike and I think frankly
that's the tone the country wants to see
we've got a load of real challenges out
there and I think we want people dealing
with them are grown-ups here as well
okay Mark Campbell thank you very much
for being on Chrome Mark at Harper there
well let's take a moment shall we and
recap on exactly where we are after
the second ballot stuella Brotherman was
out not out today with just 27 votes
actually going down from the 32 she got
last time round that means that there
are currently five candidates still in
Rishi sunak at top the pole with 101
votes any more than was second with 83
she put on the most votes compared to
last time Liz truss on 64. they came in
battle on 49 and Tom tuggerhat following
up in fifth place with 32. votes well
joining us now is the international
trade secretary Anne-Marie trevelyn who
is supporting Tom two can have hi
disappointing you went down from last
time so I'm really thrilled that Tom
through is is through to the last five
because now we're into TV debates the
opportunity to shine and indeed to
debate with all our excellent colleagues
the opportunity to test those different
policy positions that colleagues have
taken the opportunity to demonstrate
both his experience uh his quick wit and
did his humor and the depths of
convictions he has for his policy agenda
for the country and when he becomes
prime minister so you know you're
singing his Praises you're saying he's
got you know the wit and enthusiasm why
has he actually dropped MPS there in the
last uh the last 24 hours when he's been
out doing interviews and doing campaign
events so as we know this is a very
strange and rather brutal way of doing
things that we have on the conservative
party and colleagues move their votes
around a lot through the course we'll
see I'm sure more of that next week in
the next stages or votes and what we
wanted to make sure was that Tom had
enough to get through which he has
colleagues will continue to listen to
those arguments and their votes on
Monday I hope that the debate over the
weekend will help those importantly at
this point now we're starting with the
TV rates to talk to our party members uh
those who will be the next round of
voting once we have sent two candidates
to them and of course the wider
electorate who will have this candidate
selected as their prime minister until
the next general election at least so
it's really important that they have a
trust of that certainly my partner
members have already not been shy in
Sharing uh their thoughts as the process
has gone through this week the
opportunity for them to see our
candidates and to see Tom shine over the
weekend will be an important one and we
will all as MPS be hearing from our
party members and anything I have no
doubt at all from our wider constituents
about who they think would be the best
choice and Tom taking had to put out
statements where he said that he is
pleased to be through and he's going to
keep fighting did he consider folding
and he's not going to win as he he went
down one last time no he hasn't
considered voting Because he believes
that the clean status gender that it
brings and indeed the detailed policy
positions he takes the ones which need
more air time and he wants to continue
to make that case for those I hope very
much he goes all the way but if he
doesn't those issues would have been put
firmly on the table we will continue to
Champion those from the important things
like increasing defense spending to
thinking about how we manage the energy
crisis uh support the cost of living
crisis and ensure that the UK and the
union is as strong as it can be he's
absolutely passionate about ensuring
that things like the northern London
protocol bill go through because an
organizer is an integral part of the UK
so that commitment that he will
challenge no doubt his other colleagues
to over the TV rates with an opportunity
to embed what he considers to be the
most important policies we should drive
forwards it's your phone been ringing
from other counts trying to pick up your
support in future rounds I tend to keep
my phone on silent it's easier okay
that's a nice way of sidestepping that
question and I think I want to ask you a
bit as well about the tone of the debate
I would spoke to Simon Clark earlier who
said that he stands by his comments that
about Lord Frost's concerns over Penny
Warden that she's untested that there is
this at taught that she had to be moved
because she was incapable after law
Frost complained to the Prime Minister
we've also heard from him that he had
frustrations over Richardson acts
policies on tax what would you make him
surprise
so the next one of our politics is that
we have Collective responsibility in the
cabinet and decisions made in every part
of the area including the ones that
Richard's chance the major ones that we
commit to in a collective way it doesn't
mean we necessarily all agree on
everything within cabinet and we share
those issues and the Prime Minister
gives the lead in the direction at the
end of the day on what we're going to do
and that is something that we should all
and always stand by because it is a good
and solid way to provide good government
Lord Frost gave his opinions very
bluntly I agree with you and other
colleagues who will also have worked
with all the candidates will have their
own opinions these are no doubt make
them reach their own decisions on who
they want to support the untested points
is important though would you say and
this is not just an audition for the
leader of the conservative party for an
opposition leader this is an audition to
go straight into number 10. is it not a
risk to choose a relatively untested
candidate such as Tom too can or
potentially someone like Kevin maddenock
or Penny Warden
so I think Tom would make a great prime
minister because he is not untested in
leadership at all he has LED and built
in fact uh you know governments in some
of the hardest environments on Earth he
brought together uh warring Warlords in
Afghanistan who had been unable to work
together for decades and built one of
the strongest government systems that
they've seen in a long time which
withstood pretty much everything else he
has led here in the House of Commons as
the chairman of Foreign Affairs select
committee he has driven policy change
through government from that position I
have no doubt at all this is the ability
to set the agenda to lead to provide the
direction and have the intellectual
capacity to really get over the top I
mean it's a hugely busy big complex job
you're making decisions you know every
minute of the day Tom is absolutely
upset in his military training certainly
gives him the capacity to work at 100
miles an hour I think that's really
important okay and just finally while we
have you if you think it's got the
momentum in the race
genuinely I think it's hard to tell at
the moment because we're seeing everyone
sitting now in an even place and I think
the debates will uh bring out those
who've got the real energy and the skill
and they need the passion to drive
forward and Marie a trevelyn there
sticking very much to the line on Tonto
thank you indeed well it has been a very
very interesting day we have seen the
second result of the conservative party
at leadership ballot the people who have
been putting on boats showing momentum
was she sooner he crossed that 100 mp uh
line penny more than most votes she's
now on 83 in second place Liz truss on
64. Kevin badernock putting on votes on
49 relatively unknown at candidate who
is having a strong campaign so far Tom
toogen hat though dropped votes he
dropped five votes on last time but he
still made it through and Suella at
bravaman at two dropping at five votes
to make it 27 and that means she is now
eliminated let's talk now to and Deputy
Plus for editor at Sam coat shall we so
we have a breather now don't we after
the roller coaster ballots the last two
days the next ballot's on Monday how
important do you think the weekend's
going to be I mean obviously it's going
to be immensely important but I think
it's this Sudden Change of tempo of the
race that's gonna matter a great deal
one of the things that Tory MPS have
been reflecting is that in many ways
they've got this contest the wrong way
around you know because the bit to study
a large number of candidates is
happening in a really really short time
frame we had eight candidates just what
barely more than 48 hours ago and now
we're down to the last five and then
again and we so we've got rid of and
done initial assessments on uh on all of
them in that very short time frame now
there will be three days breather to go
through where people think the final two
should come from and if you look at the
numbers uh some things are quite
striking the hurdle where you need to
get to if you are a contestant if you
look at the screen where you need to get
to is 120. so Rishi sunat currently just
19 off that and you can see as further
candidates drop off from Monday onwards
you can see Rishi sunat now having a
very good dance he's still got momentum
he put on a decent number of MPS you
could still see him getting over the
line but the question I think at the
moment from today's results is who goes
into the final round with Rishi Suna and
looking at the results yes Liz trust put
on 14 but you have to see that that 64
figure it's a long way short of what the
ultimate goal needs to be going Liz
truss needs 56 more MPS to back her and
I know that the Liz trust campaign team
believe that they'll pick up many many
of the 27 that backed to Ella braveman
who went out today I think the
overwhelming majority of that 27 but
we'll just flip straight into the uh Liz
truss column but beyond that we've still
got a further uh basically a further for
the 29 to find and whilst it was the um
Liz trust Camp say they think that they
can get a lot of that from kemi
badenov's current supporters it's 4 or
less clear to me that that group won't
split many many ways and in the meantime
Penny Borden is just putting on a
proportion of the vote higher than this
trust is putting on at the moment and in
that in that Gap it just could be that
petty Morgan gets over the line and we
got we get what what the right of the
conservative party fears which is a
Rishi sunak Penny Morton final two it's
really interesting isn't it and I do
Wonder
different different
stages of the race could impact the
final outcome because we are starting to
see attacks coming at the people who are
perceived to be the Front Runners and
those are the two people Rishi sunak and
Petty Morden and things are getting
quite vicious in the briefing Wars
absolutely I think the attacks are
coming two phases phase one really was a
stop Rishi phase uh the attacks on
Richie sumac as somebody who effectively
brought down Boris Johnson who's
something of a traitor who wasn't a low
tax conservative who was blocking uh
brexit games when he was Chancellor in
uh uh inside the treasury and that felt
like it lasted from about Friday to
about yesterday then the yougov poll of
Tory members which put Penny Morden out
in front sort of changed everything and
then the most aggressive briefing war
that we were conscious of was the stock
Penny campaign now that's been happening
not below the surface but actually
remarkably uh in public David Frost Lord
Frost performed brexit negotiator for
Boris Johnson coming out saying that
Penny Warden didn't have the forensic
qualities that he would have wanted to
be prime minister he she was his Deputy
in the cabinet office when Lord Frost
was doing the brexit negotiations uh she
said that he just wasn't present at one
point he was basically she was going
missing and then that was echoed by some
other supporters of Boris Johnson but
also the cabinet member that you had on
barely 20 to 30 minutes ago Simon Clark
Chief SEC Treasury and Liz tracks trust
backer going in full you know both feet
both the double-footed tackle if that's
the phrase double-footed tackle I
believe
um isn't that impossible anyway he went
in quite hard uh
to tackle thank you uh in on um uh uh uh
on Penny Warden um live on air with you
and I think that kind of ranker that
we're seeing from a right who are
unafraid to use some fairly ballsy
tactics when it comes to uh confronting
their opponents uh reflects the
nervousness of the lack of somebody who
they regard as one of them making the
final two and therefore becoming the
next prime minister oh fascinating stuff
I really enjoyed the football and
largely there's some very impressive
there I stay there I just want to have a
quick look at that graphic again because
we can see there Rishi sunak topping the
leadership poll after today's vote 101
so he did cross that magic 100 line that
some people were looking out for some
included to show that he was picking up
support penny mordant has now on 83
votes in the second round she put on the
most votes compared to last time at
least trust also picking up support she
is on 64 that was up from 50 at last
time round can we badanoc worth keeping
an eye on Kami badinal she put on nine
votes to a 49 so again someone who's
having a very good campaign could she
have an eye on a good cabinet role at
whoever is elected a leader and then we
come to the people who've been losing
support so the people whose momentum is
going out of their campaign Tom tuga hat
he got 32 votes he's still in the
contest a bit he is dropping a support
compared to last time round and Zoella
Brotherman she's out after just picking
up a 27 vote so that's under the
Threshold at 30 that she needed to
progress last time around she's down at
five votes let's bring some coats back
in at now as shall we've been talking a
lot about that all important word
momentum
how important is it
um incredibly important because if there
is a sense amongst MPS that there are
doubts about a candidate then you can
find Tory MPS perhaps pledge support
perhaps pledge support publicly starting
to pull back vicious I thought some of
those results uh two candidates actually
going backwards in the number of support
that they've got including one that's
still in the race it's rather cruel of
you to ask Anne-Marie trevelyn backing
uh uh backing Tom tugerhart who's got
momentum this race it's very hard to
answer that your candidate has when
they're um when the number of votes that
they're getting is going down she their
Valiant effort wasn't quite able to
identify anybody I thought but that's
the problem people are having to make
very quick judgments about a very
fundamental question which will
determine the future direction of this
country at Breakneck speed and I think
what's going to happen over the next
three four days uh is um uh uh is is
essentially a process of journalists
going through the background to the
various remaining candidates MPS making
a bit more of a considered argument and
also MP's thinking uh thinking about
their own Futures because if you back a
winner publicly you've got a greater
chance of becoming uh maybe a minister
in their government than you otherwise
would do if you end up back in the wrong
person and these things don't get
forgotten they certainly don't thank you
very much uh Sam Coates well let's go
now shall we to somebody who has seen a
few at leadership air contests I'm very
interested to get his thoughts on this
one we can talk now to our chief
political Prosper John Craig who's just
over the road from us in Port color's
house and John it feels very
unpredictable even after two rounds of
boating
well there was no big winner from that
round was there if you look at the
numbers and I'm sure you've talked about
them already but I mean I I was in the
room for the result and then in the
corridor where a spokesman for the
various candidates were spinning and
I've actually just been on all the
terrorists talking to some conservative
MPS as well but it was interesting I
mean um sunac is only up 13 Morden is up
16 and trust is up 14. so there's no
real big Gainer there and of course um
um chugan heart to some MPS thought
might drop out uh if he did not improve
on his vote first time well of course
his vote's down five and of course
Suella bravaman's vote was down now so
after the announcement out in the
corridor you'll be familiar with that
narrow Corridor outside the committee
rooms committee room 14. first we had
Simon Clark I think you may have just
interviewed Sophie I'm not sure but he
was spinning for uh Liz truss and he was
saying that this was always a difficult
found for the Liz there wasn't a very
large pool to fish in and one Tory MP
whose predictions have been very good
not not any of the ones we've named it
was predicted predictions have been good
throughout this contest is saying now
could be an all-women final now another
Tory MP I've spoken to the other person
spinning incidentally in the corridor
was Mark Harper for Rishi sunac denying
all those claims about lending votes and
so on and if you look at the numbers
actually if Mr sunax only up 13 well uh
and given the other numbers it's
probably right perhaps not I think it's
probably a bit early for all that sort
of thing trying to keep one or other
candidate out but I was talking to an
influential Tory MP
um who said to me just now
deals need to be done over the weekend I
think that's something that Sam Coates
was alluding to a moment or two ago I've
heard that from a senior MP just now
Braverman and badanot can be the queen
maker we don't often talk about a queen
maker do it's normally King maker for
truss or mordant it would require trust
or Morden to toughen their stance on
getting out of in getting out of the
European Court of human rights which
would go down very well with the
membership and um the other point that
that particular MP was saying to me the
principled in inverted Commerce career
is supporting Rishi sunak must be
starting to wonder if they're backing
the right horse or if they've hitched
their wagons to the right Wagon Train oh
dear some Dreadful mixed meth Medicals
there but never mind
um and another the mimp is a good
predictor of these things said the only
reason for Tom tugenhart to carry on and
go into the next contest is that he'll
then get to see another set of results
that will give him a better indicator as
to who to throw his weight behind when
he gets kicked out I mean he looks like
the next one to uh to get kicked out as
all MP put it to me but it's interesting
now we're sort of at the halfway stage
aren't we of the MPS voting or perhaps
yeah I think we probably are at the
halfway stage
and clearly everybody's now talking
about deals and uh intriguingly there
are doubts now amongst MPS about Rishi
sunak whether he will make the final two
that is new because of course there were
some MPS saying that really Rishi sunak
needed to be up to
um 120 or so in this round to get a
commanding lead he's not he's only just
scraped into three figures 101 and now
it is fair to say and it's been said
here already by senior MPS that it could
be trust versus mordant in the final two
that go to the members are not Rishi
sunak and either and one of Liz truss or
uh Penny Morden so that's what the MPS
are saying both here in this part of
Parliament and also in the corridors and
out in the sunshine on the Terrace I bet
you're dead jealous you've not been out
there Sophie but um the prospect now of
trust versus mordant in the runoff of
the vote of party members is now being
talked about by MPS and some are
suggesting that Rishi Sue Knack might
not make the final two
there you go John I am a bit jealous
actually of you soaking up the sunshine
while also of course having all those
conversations with MPS as I know that
you are John Craig there is talking
about how the tone of the debate and who
could even be in that final two is now
starting to change could it be that
Richard C note doesn't make the final
cut he's still certainly would be the
favorite to do so he managed to pick up
101 MPS today but now there is perhaps
some speculation that the people with
momentum Penny mordant getting to 83
putting on the most votes as last time
Liz Trust on 64 perhaps a slower start
than she expected but could she benefit
from swella Brotherman being out of a
cup of content contest all to play for
after the second ballot of conservative
party MPS before it goes over to the
members more coverage coming up in just
a few moments time